je veux bien que tu as un problème avec
notre équipe mais quand même n'abuse pas
s'il te plaît merci
[Musique]
ce qui m'a plu au premier abord en fait
dans ce sport c'est la solidarité un peu
Kia quoi c'est à dire sur le terrain on
est des adversaires contre les équipes
adverses on les adversaires on est des
guerriers en s'affront et en dehors de
ça en fait à côté de ça ben les gars
après le premier match sont venus me
voir ils m'ont dit ouais il faut que tu
essayes de t'attacher comme s'il faut
que tu essayes de t'équiper comme ça
c'est pas mal ce que tu fais et en fait
j'ai dit oh c'est bizarre quoi comme
mentalité j'ai trouvé ça trop cool quoi
et c'est pour ça que j'ai accroché assez
rapidement
[Musique]
tu pousses fort quand même éviter de
d'être trop près de lui parce que dès
qu'il vous met la grille dans la roue
pour s'en sortir c'est assez compliqué
quoi c'est c'est vraiment le même les
plus grands joueurs au monde le
redoutent quoi quand il voit Cédric et
qui se disent ouh là là s'il est sur moi
donc voilà et puis c'est il s'arrête pas
quoi
merci
toutes
les gars
[Musique]
j'espère que les stades seront plein qui
auraient du public qui viendra nous
supporter et nous soutenir parce qu'on
sait que ça peut ça peut que nous aider
normalement mais après voilà quoi c'est
sûr que des jeux à la maison ce sera une
grande première ça va se présenter
qu'une seule fois dans notre vie donc le
but c'est vraiment tout donner pour pas
avoir déception à la fin
[Musique]
je suis allé vers les bases
on a vraiment besoin que le grand public
puisse avoir un autre rapport avec avec
le handicap dans ce pays et là de
d'avoir d'inviter le monde entier à
venir faire cette grande fête du sport
ça va vraiment ouvrir les esprits on a
besoin d'accessibilité évidemment dans
le bâti dans les infrastructures on a
surtout une besoin d'accessibilité dans
les esprits de chacun et de chacune
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mis un petit handicap en plus parce
que l'équipe en face a été pas encore
été pas trop folle donc du coup j'ai mis
4 kg sur mon sur mon fauteuil c'était
pas
[Rires]